we're here today to film her separating
an Oreo so we came up with this idea to
have different machines builders
roboticists separate the Oreo to their
favorite party another cookie the cream
the media goat cheese was Carnegie
Mellon University's herb which is a
perfect choice because he's it's a robot
Butler we really are focusing on trying
to get her to do the kind of toss that I
can't give over to perform for you in
the home and that's the goal and we're
developing technologies that can enable
her to do that but really it's quite
fascinating that we can take those
technologies that are so useful and
pretty quickly adapt them for something
as fun as separating the cookies and the
cream from the Oreo know her rarely does
what we tell them to how do you feel
about her success I'm jealous I think
he's getting a lot of attention there's
a lot of people walking by maybe they
realized that it's about me and I'm not
so sure yet they know I feel more like a
parent but there's a little bit of
sibling rivalry here I don't know I have
to see how successful he is it's nice
that he's failing a few times well it's
actually been a real challenge to get
her to do the Oreo task interestingly
it's one of the smallest objects that
we've actually ever manipulated with her
and so herb has been having a really
exciting time finding ways to pick up
Oreos and separate or his because
they're so small and delicate in
comparison technically packaged goods
and large tents and things that we've
been typically focusing on it's a kind
of a prima donna
stay humble stay humble you're not sure
who's gonna go out in the world and do a
lot of things but you know that he
should never forget where he came from
the state earlier school yeah it was
true